dude one time i remember being in toledo  and they had like an arsonist recovery  group  and i'm all about recovery you know that  12 steps i'm on 144 steps man i need all  i need to just constantly be on the  staircase  but these boys he's with some arsonists  just a bunch of damn  candle zorros i mean they'll [ __ ]  light a candle and just  you know burn down a damn dog house or  something  and i respect him and stuff but that you  know that's the kind of people that were  out there getting free tickets  people that's used to burning down  hospital you know  arsonists people that does arson  you know the kind of guy who lights a  cigarette and that ain't enough  then next thing you know he's like oh  he'll hold that lighter against the side  of a damn  federal building for an hour and a half  one dude was throwing lit matches on the  stage what bruh  what are you doing dude